hi welcome to the monitor as always I am
Peter Reuben scene senior editor senior
editor I don't know what that is senior
editor at Wired and this week we are
talking about a movie that's kind of a
first we're talking about a video game
that's kind of a movie and we're going
to talk about a TV show that's kind of
the best thing ever so let's start with
that and that is Louie on the FX network
and i would like to assume that you've
watched the first two seasons if you
haven't you can do that they're all
available on DVD probably on demand
somewhere it has become the one of the
smartest one of the most talked about a
bull which is not a word I'm going to
coin that now neologism week on the
monitor talk about it will you just
after you see an episode of Lou you just
want to kind of share it with people you
want to talk about your favorite moments
it is if you don't know Louie CK
esteemed veteran comic basically rights
and a lot of times shoots the entire
thing himself it is just the story of
one man getting his ass kicked by New
York week after week after week it's
grim and it's stark and it's
heartwarming and heartbreaking and
hilarious and season three starts this
week I don't want to tell you too much
about it but I will be watching it again
and I suggest you do the same even if
it's for the first time so let's talk
about that comic book that's kind of a
video game is kind of a movie that's
actually a video game but is all three
and one to our correspondent all right
let's let's talk about Lego video games
they've been around for a little while
since the original lego star wars games
and I was a huge fan love the lego star
wars games love the first lego batman
started to fall off the wagon a little
bit or at least the bandwagon very
different from falling off the wagon
fell off the bandwagon a little bit when
it got a little diluted in my opinion so
Harry Potter wasn't that into prior to
the Caribbean stuff not that into
however however lego batman 2 colon DC
superheroes is out this week
and I'm back I'm back so not only do you
get the lego batman experience with all
the characters Batman Robin Alfred bane
Ra's al Ghul Harley Quinn etc etc but
ton of other DC characters Superman
Supergirl General Zod is in there
Hawkman a Green Lantern Wonder Woman it
is a it's a panoply it's a panoply of DC
superheroes hence the sir title DC
superheroes so that is out this week not
as exorbitantly priced as a lot of
Triple A games as a nice thing about the
Lego titles so if you have a spare 40
bucks pick it up play the hell out of it
back to you alright thanks for that so
movies this week steven soderbergh's
stripper male stripper comedy magic mike
is out which is kind of flabbergasting
and is probably a lot of fun but let's
instead talk about Ted which is Seth
MacFarlane creator writer voice actor
for the family guy and american dad and
the cleveland show is has written and
directed his first live-action movie and
well it's pretty Seth MacFarlane so it's
about a teddy bear who well you know
smokes weed curses all the time enjoys
the company of professional escorts your
typical romantic comedy character but
mark wahlberg and mila kunis is kind of
a conventional rom-com with a giant
injection of foul mouth stuffed animal
played by Seth MacFarlane one beef is
that he uses the exact same voice uses
for Brian the dog on family guy Nick
come on dude like you do how many voices
on the various shows that you oversee
let's let's come up with a new one what
do you say but still but still Ted's
going to get our haiku review of the
week what does this feel mother made
right it's Ted so that's it for this
week on the monitor my virgin ears are
burning I'm sorry I'm gonna go wash my
mouth out with soap
always email us at the monitor at
wired.com let me know what you think we
should be talking about comic-con is
coming up soon what should we be excited
what should we go cover what should we
do what am I doing wrong tell me that I
need to be punished but until we come
back next week with more pop culture
awesome inspirational catchphrase here
you